The fifth section is titled variables. Design studies themselves have to
be designed. In particular the independent and dependent variables must be
identified and appropriate metrics specified. Design studies,
like experiments, allow designers, like scientists, to alter conditions and
note results. The altered conditions comprise the independent variables. And
the corresponding results comprise the dependent variables each variable has
a unique name a description and a unit of measurement such as seconds. Sometimes
the units are easy for example time other variable such as maintainability
require you to think carefully and invent an appropriate way to measure it. But
this section of the design study describes the variables, both independent and
dependent, the units and measures, and how the research questions address them.
The section should also include a summary table, with three columns, which for
each research question, lists the independent and
dependent variables you used, in answering the question.